la vieille s'arrête à 18 heures on n'a
pas le docteur h et de choses et
maintenant le duc le week-end à enfermer
et
[Musique]
sur 100 boutiques des rues comment
ouverte il va y avoir à peu près entre
25 et 30 qui vont faire du click and
collect peut-être plus si jamais ça
fonctionne bien et peut-être moins si
les gens voient que finalement ça marche
pas il risque de laisser tomber de
fermer
[Musique]
j'ai rappelé toute ma clientèle des deux
prochains samedis pour modifier leur
rendez vous on our aussi la place des
rendez vous du lundi dans le monde
sommes fermes émanant de sa moue verts
on avait déjà changé nos horaires avec
le couvre-feu on ouvre à 9 heures le
matin on ferme à 18 heures voilà on
essaie de s'adapter au maximum pour
travailler correctement répondre à toute
la demande et respecter la loi